[Music]
it's a destiny day what time what's up
Eric yeah that's neat Tuesday's I guess
reset
reset Jesus I'm Rob this is Eric and
we're taking a look at
[Music]
so we had an update last night right
mm-hmm
well technically that they came out
yesterday but the faction bulks didn't
show up till today so we're oblong he
followed me because I don't think you've
done the quest yet he's gonna change his
monitor here so you can see but just so
you guys know we're checking out your
guys's comments in the chat youtubes
which can you spot etc thank you guys
yep gentlemen he knows the game volume
is loud thanks for telling us he turned
it down already I think sir there's so
many moving parts now you're okay
other way other way come this way hanger
on it all right so I'm gonna you guys
have me my feed right now so you guys
are gonna see that I'm gonna open up a
bunch of packages we're going to show
you guys where all the factions people
are they're technically on the map but
if you were curious dead orbits and
future work halt or we close to each
other Rob's got to do the quest anyways
so hopefully thank God yesterday night
like or 2:00 in the morning or whatever
it's kind of buggy like they weren't
always there I had to go to orbit a
bunch of times so here's our buddy
rock Jalal let's bomb some packages for
the stream here I haven't opened any yet
hopefully we get the the class Armour is
what we're hoping for here I did not I
got the hand cannon that I already have
which is kind of happy but I got the
dead orbit Raider that's what matters
Rob all right we got the cloak let's get
low get high
still out and how is this 300 that we
can bomb it in this guy all right let's
go let's go dead orbit
hold on and we got to rock the dead
orbit class armor cuz I'm about dead
orbit life look I don't know what class
classes are uh I'm sorry what factions
you guys allow yourselves to but dead
orbit is the best faction hands down so
get out of here titan mark whatever
cloak same [ __ ] can I see the dead orbit
shaders sure I'll show you that in a
second I got the eleventh hour which is
a sidearm from dead orbit I can show you
guys that here actually I'll show you
guys this this is easier probably I
haven't got any dead orbit armor sans
the mark but this is what a Titan would
look like here's one of the two shaders
dead orbits fate so it's pretty cool
like it black and white yep very
refreshment of destiny one I forget the
exact name then it's looting me like
bitter steel like they're all kind of
the same we're reversed there's only two
shaders right now this one this is
pretty much like black camo the other
ones more of a black and white so random
which one you get obviously there's four
weapons they can get three graves that'd
be nice to get probably so we got two of
the weapons ready here's the arm where
you can also get the winners offering
which is a new thing Rob so all the
factions kind of battle it out and
whichever faction wins I think you get
to buy this gun for a thousand glimmer
for the week so we're gonna open up
another package oh we got three graves
nice alright look at all the coops
yeah I've farmed a lot this morning
slash last night we got another hand
cannon which sucks
and we got a chest piece cool all right
so we got let's see how many shaders we
got we got a bomb the dead orbit shaders
right like we got to rob I was rocking
give to the nine but now we got oh we
got both alright what do you what is
your vote are you all about the black
the black and white or did you like the
all-black better there you go that's
more like a gray I'm a fan of the
all-black very threatening okay all
right we'll go with the all-black since
rob is a things I'm a threatening kind
of guy yeah definitely all right let's
do like gloves dead orbit camo here kind
of gonna miss my gift guide sometimes it
doesn't apply you don't hold it down all
the way kind of gonna miss my gift of
the nine in a little bit here but that's
alright it's for the stream it's for the
stream for the stream kind of curious
that there's no like purple like shader
or uh like legendary shader mmm there's
only a blue one but you know what can
you do
boom we can load up I don't think
there's a need to do it on the Titan
mark I don't know if it actually makes
that much of a difference it does not so
I'm not gonna waste a shader so there
you go
that's dead orbit I'll show you guys
where futureworld Carl yeah future war
cult even is that did you redo that are
you doing that yeah you're doing that
you're you're over at had a OH
aren't you did you do for sure well no
probably not
oh you got to come back to where we were
she was like right behind or like above
a rock Jill all you're gone the wrong
way I totally am i over the hangar you
got sorry I'm looking at his screen
while playing my screen yeah yeah we
played over [ __ ] fate alright Jared
nice sorry no he played a lot last night
yep we did we did some trials last night
at like 11:30 a.m. we got almost 5 5 oh
we lost that 5 Oh match 6 5 which is a
tough loss there but uh end up going 5 1
god she's some powerful gear you never
done trials before so you did a pretty
good job I did once before but it just
didn't but you know what I mean like you
didn't have like actual experience yeah
yeah there's a lot what's up gaming
Titan as far as like I mean obviously
strategy but like knowing the map and
like where to like you know
so accept that and then we're gonna run
on over to Hideo have you decided who
you want to faction up with yet Rob
where you kind of like you know I had to
pick one before we do this nightfall
that's for sure that's fair you you kind
of uh I mean what faction did you roll
with shahrullah dude I roll dead orbit
because I'm dead orbit for life well
technically for work purposes I have one
of each character technically so I have
one of each faction gotcha so
technically I'm pretty neutral but in my
heart of hearts I'm a dead orbit guy and
I will always be a dead orbit guy now
granted you know every faction has
different weapons I can't show you the
stuff on this character but we can check
that out later or you can actually check
out the gallery that we put up on
GameSpot I worked with Oscar Dyess this
morning and I basically basically show
all the weapons and at least one armored
set per faction so alright we're on our
way to Hideo he's near the ramen area
and yeah he's just kind of off to the
side here are the weapon types like as
far as like class or like type of weapon
are they your ultra specific to like
factions or is it just kind of like
these are these are specific to factions
so each faction has its own weapons now
you're not able to preview it except for
though the winners okay
weapon but they have four weapons that
you can get that are unique to them I
technically have one from like a Cates -
here's the one for my time this week
it's a sidearm for new monarchy god that
reminds me of the Master Chief
Magnum from the first so Jon week says
he's going to monarchy so you can decide
who you want to go I think that dead
orbits gonna win every week but I could
be wrong I could totally be wrong but uh
John Luke says plus he likes that red
and gold yeah they have a red and gold
shader the armor for warlock look pretty
good for you you want our key so I'm
glad I picked that one if I aligned with
the faction is that permanent it's not
necessarily permanent but it's like one
of those things were like ice on a
weekly basis kind of thing so I would
choose wisely
I believe if it still works the same way
I'm not a hundred percent sure on that
occupy correct me Marcel we are playing
on ps4 all three of us I'm gonna get
John Luke here in a second we're gonna
do the nightfall it's the pyramidion so
want the lasers and kind of like a Theon
and away
there's the modifiers this week is that
I forget the name of it actually I could
look it up on the destinations so
where's the dead orbit that orbits back
in the hangar like all the way back
where we were all right well screw it
alright so here we go
torrent apparently allows us to have our
abilities faster which is pretty good
and then time warp zero hour means that
we don't actually get any way to add
time this week so it's about it's kind
of like a race but I heard you get 22
minutes which is pretty generous so
we'll just wait on Rob to get on his
dead orbit faction and then when it
won't be a monarchy oh you want a new
monarchy yeah you scrub or the stream
I'm changing it up no John legs going
new monarchy anyway is cool alright
whatever you guys can be you guys can be
new monarchy Oh heathens oh yeah that's
right I said it
it's all about it's all about faction
allegiances didn't you know that Rob no
I didn't know you didn't okay I do know
that's fair okay do you oh I'm not a key
new more not gate [ __ ] I don't have my
best loadout here and I think that thing
is kind of broken dead to me just good
my app is broken I think
why is he future war cult get out of
here future well let's see if the app is
working here yesterday for whatever
reason it was it was down so hopefully
come today okay I know I don't want to
sign into a Wi-Fi network
alright so are you good I'm good alright
I'm gonna take us to orbit real quick
you probably need to switch out your
loadout a bit if you can
what would you recommend oh I would go
nameless midnight for sure to go to
scout here there you go and then your
heals is fine yeah that's fine it's
probably diversify my elements here oh
yeah sure diversify your portfolio while
I try to
well I try to let's see let me get John
Luke up in this send him a hot invite I
have the war come on if destiny app
thing oh yes it's working today oh yes
okay well at least it working on that
character let's see if I can get my name
no no only working on one character
which is kind of huh
crappy cuz my nameless midnight is on my
hunter Michael thir
oh my app just froze hi tight it's okay
we got some time whoa
well we stretching getting that good
stretch on before this uh yeah okay
Charles was fun last night though yeah
it's definitely it takes patience I mean
like we were getting rolled at times too
so but yeah I think that once you kind
of get used to it you can hopefully
establish like a group and that group
will definitely help you out I have a
285 midnight I guess we could rock with
that like it was it was interesting like
uh I mean yeah the other time I played
it seemed we were just like you know
just all over the place but last night
like just that like when you're
attacking like having one person like
you were going up to like you know the
keyhole and like just kind of scouting
well like you kind of all push for yeah
it definitely changes strats and stuff
like that and then um all right well
alright John looks honest let's see what
he's rocking tried to as you had
mentioned diversify our portfolios a
little bit here although it the modifier
stuff probably won't matter as much I
don't know if he's gonna run that or not
that seems real crazy John Luke to go
sidearm in a submachine gun but I was
handed I will not necessarily judge
alright hey what's up Josh all win tase
Wednesday gonna carry us through the
raid and that's a good question
that's a good question Josh that will
take a lot of explaining although Rob is
technically beat the raid I did okay
disgusting like John Luke hit me up I
was like we're on the last that's fine
you did just like hopped in and got my
stuff here we go
man that mean I was pretty intense when
I did on he hasn't changed his gear yet
he wrote that in all caps to make sure I
knew I guess yelling guys alright here
we go he's got a scout and anything
there we go
why am I at work when I should be
playing this ask mr. Jack well that's a
good question that's the beauty of our
jobs we that we don't take for granted
obviously and we we thank you guys for
your continuing support for us to be
able to do what we love to do and play
games I work I get to play destiny at
least for now every Tuesday which is
awesome yeah that's pretty awesome
I don't mind that at all mr. dreadful
but you're here with us you're playing
with yeah exactly it's the best of both
worlds I think not really you should be
playing by yourself
whatevs I don't like my ship I know it's
a dumb thing to complain about but I
liked your I liked your ship yeah you
just get lucky forgiven monster gaming
yeah I've had my ups and downs with PvP
I think I like iron banner I just trials
is fine
it makes me rage II and I don't want to
be Reggie but the PvE stuff is really
good
then den a little son line Lane says
this nightfall is very easy I hope
that's true because you know I would
like to do an eyeball on the first try
and in the first of these three weeks I
mean if we stop through this though what
are we gonna show the streamer do we can
show all the factions stuff Oh duh yeah
yeah so there's a bunch of stuff we can
show them tariffs regarding the factions
so there's that so we got 21 minutes now
21:35 let's hopefully get through this I
kind of feel like that guy just set us
up for failure though a little bit what
do you mean because he said it's easy
like you know like kind of take it for
granted right you just start playing
like relax yeah my gran needs his pulse
grenades or opium this game all right we
got to stand on these platforms Josh
we'll figure out a time to try to figure
out who who's available to do said raid
Oh what the hell why did okay this is
not good
Robin stuff is miss one here a second
which we're gonna have to kill without
John oh god oh god I'm down okay well
that's fine I blamed John Luke for this
really same it booted him for some
reason that was not a ideal scenario
obviously and I don't know where the
hell John Luke is a good start you know
just a really really welcoming start
goop says white that type is being
screwy well you should so join like
we've done this before like we're all on
the same like that
yeah it's I don't know then remember the
last night ball we have problems with
errands to be arranged some stuff brandy
that was kind of like just like in-game
bug that was not so yeah like connection
yeah it was not connection yeah that's
fair that's his fare all right we gotta
get the other one feel like we lost a
lot of time there but yeah probably you
know whatever we can step it up I'm new
to it though goblins and sentinels
always make me waste grenades that's
pretty accurate
using the prospector checking that guy
out the old prospector the old
prospector watch out some [ __ ] isn't
gonna spawn too bad [ __ ] I'm not about
to die the same way and John Luke lies
in with the sparrow
whoa badass you'll Hecky like a knife
through that oh hey maybe those guys
hurt a little bit
yep feeling like that one guy said mr.
failure I'm throwing down some hot milk
that sounds awful
no but it's not okay alright you say so
I don't know man when you hear someone
say hey remember use grenades a lot and
your abilities because we get a lot of
recharge same with you John Luke if you
can hear this I'm not even doing it so
fast yeah we should be yeah I did that
might be we should be spamming them less
spam why is that because the one of the
things that's the modifiers this week is
that I think the torrent gives you this
yeah we got a we got a book it a little
bit I think this is a pretty long
nightfall so Dukes of Hazzard appearance
by John Luke says Amish war machine that
was pretty Dukes of Hazzard yeah gross
goob wants that milk okay you regret it
right yeah last week's nightfall was
pretty tough yeah that's true for a
forgive forgiven monster gaming I think
that the key to last week was the
shooting as many anomalies as possible
or you could have cheesed it technically
because there was that one anomaly that
like took forever who the alright he's
tough he's seriously like warping
remember granada's and all that stuff
travel off we're going straight down
right yeah just keep throwing chucking
grenades oh this is oh I remember
remember this one this is what my
favorites yeah this was really cool the
animators it's got the little puzzle
let's go yeah these guys are
oh dude that's the worst the double
goblins standing each other giving them
Oh Karen
oh you're crazy
yeah well now I'll just do this okay
that's good yeah yeah we should be
spamming supers - I don't know why I'm
not doing that either
I'm so used to saving it yeah you got
him sick all right let's go spam some
supers what what I totally completed
John if I can revive you it's not
working Wow
sorry John Luke it's not working I'm
like I'm seeing the dial like old myself
no I'm seeing the dial like neither live
he's alive he's alive
well it's alive he's 100% alive down
there oh my god so I'm just seeing a
duplicate yeah yeah it goes is some type
of reflection type I don't know where
the hell he's going how's my body oh now
he's back do you see my body I see you I
get it just just go just go just go I'm
responding let's go this is this has
been a real awkward that's that's all so
far I mean we're testing I feel like
John Luke is like a ghost that keeps
yeah and no he's darling
he's definitely warm during his phase
and he's like I take him he oh my god
Josh said Wow Rob did a super without a
sound effect whoa weird Josh Josh and I
play whenever I do my my [ __ ] aim what's
the art what's the super for arc what
are class or McCall stormcaller excuse
me I do if I do a funny thing he likes
where I pretend I'm actually like a
patina
no but I'm more more like I'm I pretend
that I'm actually suffering oh my god
that was jump we can't go back up to get
you I kind of blew that I was talking
yes I pretend I'm being actually being
electrocuted that's fair I'll do it now
Josh I'll do it when it's appropriate
how close are you
Rob don't explain it yeah that was
coming I'm coming I'm here
very angry
one of the situation here
whatever
that's right Nate's family
I'm doing super all right do it
get him get him up I've heard of this
guy at all that work kind of the hell
oh yeah be spamming your your thing -
well this is a real hairy situation
god I hate this gun
oh my god so is that the only modifier
just like cooldowns yeah pretty much
just for us pulldown for us
therefore we could like be beasting
really
goddamn the name
feel like we're wasting too much time
killing this stuff we don't need to oh
there's a beat the taken Oh does it okay
well there you go
I was wrong here I go
Chuck in those maids yep thank you
all right let's go we got a hack I think
something now no we got something oh
yeah I like this part we got a what's in
my eye
feeling great right now Rob you're not
feeling great feeling great try to rush
it that was bad
oh really you can't route oh wow my
ghost is in there that's really shitty
oh can you revive us okay I can't
you're the best right now you're dead
oh dude it put you all the way back in
the back okay so yeah okay this is their
way of touch kind of eating up time I
guess is if you fail you just get
freaking put like really far behind
really far back okay fair enough
nope oh [ __ ] I was gonna pivot to go get
you and that was yeah this is how you
lose time right here man I like can't
rush these no you really can't
I'm sorry I like hunters I hate hunters
I like Todd else let's be good about
this it's stop feeling besides open good
call
you're gonna wait for this guy to go
away and run straight you okay so far so
good
wait for this guy to go away and run
straight through how's everyone looking
I'm okay I'm taking our super slow roll
don't die on this part where the laser
is kind of like going in out wait very
Rob we're gonna stuff
Oh a lease are down here all right fine
you read them we gotta go although I
want to say the boss is after this part
oh wait no we still got a long way to go
actually
we got to hold these plates and then we
still got to hack some stuff then we got
to fight the boss
then you see that guy over there
like write the answer right
gotta kill the goblins ooh they're gonna
oh I'm in the middle I should have
jumped out
John encounter now
please spawn
just three altars or you guys activate
bear one right there
yeah super we think our chances oh god
damn that's right now I'm not very good
because we have eight minutes we still
have to do this hacky part of some diet
yeah only did I don't know I don't know
we still got a ways to go
you kill everything all right okay so we
got to hack this next part and then we
still gotta kill the boss so let's start
you see the sniper yeah I can take it
Boyd can't we do this again I'm going to
put
one might still have a chance
yeah
move it move it
Oh
oh man
Oh
no I got body blocked by the frickin
thing trying to see what I knew move how
do you gain time you can't gain time
this week Anthony Bates you just have 22
minutes so yeah you just got to be fast
this week and use your abilities because
your abilities regen like really quickly
well stamp I'm that all gone but John
Luke is literally teleporting on the
screen that's why
think he's trying to attack that blower
one what's up Claire thanks for joining
oh you're up yep we trying to make a big
play
he played all super
oh did not what else is left
can you not hack when you're in super I
guess not
hopefully he got that other one and if
so we got it oh no no no we did all
right can we go through yeah yeah go
through the gate just go through the
girl man go through the gate okay 100%
yeah yeah we got to do the boss here in
five minutes
oh my god all right here we go
what's up women what's your clan name
game spot shoutouts please with some
clear cross as BB mentioned you don't
gain time you get 22 minutes plenty of
time I don't know man we got five
minutes so Rob how this guy works is
he's gonna show up we're gonna damage
him then he's gonna go into these backs
back corners one of them first
and then we have to stand on the plates
to get him right right but you can still
snipe through okay I'm gonna start it
just remember do you have healing right
yeah it's equipped right yeah like okay
we got to spam that later but not now
obviously we triggered the boss all
right get the hell away get the hell
away even this
both of those needs
all right so he's going to the back
right now careful
play next yeah just like a hog God would
come back Oh
feeling ripped over here when and then
we're gonna have to do one we're gonna
have to go back to that other side right
but he comes out right yeah after the
second one yeah this remember he changes
up the terrain
yep
he's out in a bowl for damage
look after the fire
are you teleporting to the other side
now not sure where the first plate is I
think my view okay we just keep it
frosty yeah yeah yeah when you get there
obviously ripped no too far oh yeah I do
that a lot to like slip
other one
rip I'm almost there on the roof okay
just don't die here don't die here just
hide this I decide okay we're not I
don't know he's probably he's out yep
should I go up in there super mode on
superhero super save your super to clear
ads later yeah
you can teleport again I think he's
frontside now yeah
his head is garnishes are no I just got
staggered never keep trucking those two
maids
yeah really check that one oh [ __ ] what
middle
huge grenades are so good
particularly cover away he would
yeah
[Music]
oh this an adequate house oh crap
now we're all down it's uh gonna be
scheduled got a minute and 15 seconds
revised closed so it's gonna come down
to the wire we have 50 seconds how much
okay yeah super used it I didn't need to
use it I mean like you don't have any
more right no okay okay this is
seriously gonna come down to the wire I
really I should try to just do as much
no no no don't just do as much damage as
you can to the bosses yeah he's really
low right now just keep chucking it all
up the juicing gene don't worry baby it
was really dirty but uh yeah so very
doable 20 seconds on the clock
seconds left five it could be done
better I think you just have to
definitely bring void weapons guys beat
it gang
and I was lagging as f yeah I know I saw
go get your loot Jesus that was so like
it's actually this nightfall to me to be
honest is easier than last week's yeah
so if you guys are struggling with last
week's I think this week just if you're
a Titan obviously double pulse grenade
is o P you saw me using them to some
effect
I was definitely struggling a little bit
there obviously but uh double pulse is
grenade is really o P so do that
obviously you can spam your class
abilities healing rips it look like I
could put up two shields at one time so
yeah I think good job Rob we did it yeah
it was it was not a clean run but it's
all about doing it so nice down to the
viruses forgiving monster yeah we did it
we did it down to the why GG Marvin have
T we did it gg gg alright so now that we
did the nightfall we can do some of our
like kind of like our clan chores or so
to speak I've done some of the stuff but
I can help you guys out like let's go
we'll go to like IO
yes actually yeah we got I oh I guess oh
no no the public events are up so there
are new kind of like public events in a
way because like ever since a faction
came like there's these like almost like
side public events that we're happening
during these other public events and I
guess that just must be uh because of
the new factions are they how different
are they um they're just different
because I've never seen them they like
they require you to like sit on a point
we just did normal Bernardo but I'm
pretty sure this would be a doable
prestige mode if you're going to try to
do prestige our third guy was lag in
pretty bad you don't know I wasn't the
prestige I would assume you have less
than 22 minutes in the prestige what was
it like seven during the first couple so
I wouldn't be shocked if you have like
seventeen sixteen or seventeen
extinction to a for our client is
GameSpot we're almost level four we're
doing some doing some work here we just
finished a night fall for the the clan
Rob that's pretty hot so our clan can go
get a nightfall a powerful Engram I
think from Hawthorne so if you guys
aren't in a clan you guys should
consider joining a clan because of the
benefits of getting free loops
essentially now I'm not sure if the
trials of the nine or the raid loop is
bugged because it Colin comes out level
ten but at least you get raid and trials
here even if you don't participate in
those activities which is pretty cool I
know like Aaron's gotten the sword from
the raid and some other stuff just from
us completing it on a weekly basis so
that's definitely a perk also since
we're level three I think we have that
like I don't know it's like that buff
where we get more drops from public
events also I'm gonna pop a bright coin
because why the eff not I'm feeling good
Rob oh damn that's awesome I'm feeling
good I'm feeling pretty generous here so
yeah I think I did this lost sector oh
did you refresh
now we could go do that lost sector in a
second and you guys can see what some of
the so the new faction like kind of
quest that they have you do is like to
do lost sectors and I don't have it here
but by doing like about five or six lost
sectors
you'll get coins for your faction and
then by finishing that quest re you'll
get sixteen there's quite a bit
obviously
yeah I would say if you were thinking
about doing the procedure I think this
week is really especially with all the
class abilities I think it's totally
doable
especially if you like just have like
double playing I think I saw a lot of
weight shields so as long as you have a
void damage to this week's nightfall
which I should have just switched to my
Uriel's gifts we would have rolled
through that or even graviton Lance
probably would have beasted I could've
had that but it doesn't matter now
irrelevant so we'll see if the other
public event triggers when this one does
I don't know if it will it did for me
earlier but things random the other
public event only gave us for when you
do heroic public events you get eat plan
tokens which is pretty cool do you know
how to do this one wrong okay a little
black stuff in the game what's the
heroic that just a guy swansea and kiln
yeah pretty big boy this visit
okay job
like how it just does like so much
damage I mean that's how it was getting
all the kills and I might die here
level that's fine
nice alright we're just basically kind
of killed again all right we're going to
the next spot
/ oh I didn't see this shortcut no dude
this door here that's smart
what's actually weird is doing Iowa
because Iowa is a flat point this week
and I just never go to I oh yeah I never
I barely go to Titan either so it's like
really weird wish I had the rocket
launcher or curtain call
so also the other really strong thing is
rocket launches with cluster bombs huh
you're like really strong grabbed on
lance right no just rocket launchers
with a cluster bomb no I said that wrong
the award every time amount like that's
a that's a type that does that oh you
bored if coil it does like a like bread
kind of things like a secondary hail of
bearnaise right
mistake [ __ ] wait where's humming stops
now he's over there too
actually he's like okay damn you John
Luke well played I see what you're doing
damn we're not doing enough damage to
this thing why the only one shooting it
I was I got now we have one more chance
to get this oh hang on hang on there
goes that oh we're back we're back and
we're back and wait why is the thing
guard oh no that is some hot garbage all
right well that sucks all right well let
me show you the lost sector yeah let's
change it up yeah
prosecutors really did if you guys
haven't gone yet but it's through trials
I think I had that I know some people
were getting lucky and getting it yeah
drops you guys see where it went
so yeah yeah yeah so like no no it's not
new right it's just that now they
actually like I don't know it's like
bungees way of getting you to do more
lost sectors and you did before because
what wasn't really a reason to but now
you get coins from doing it
I still think heroic public events are
the way to go cuz they're faster yeah
because if you do heroic public event
you get eight these are only given about
like three unless you get a really big
loss sector yeah like this one's a big
one I think I did I just did this one
earlier it's kind of cool that it's
letting me do it again especially
certain types of her events like the the
taken Walker drop one yeah I feel like
I've like just last night I was like
mess around it's like just breezing
through those oh okay yeah so you guys
killed that thing I wanted to show what
it was but we got a token what was it
there's things that you need to kill
it's like supply stuff and basically if
you do the supply stuff you get you'll
get the coins so there's one right there
I wandering all right so if you shoot it
it's gonna explode though and then we'll
get a coin and then we clear this area
out
oh well yeah I personally would just say
do your to get this stuff but now public
events is also another way
I mean you're kind of doing them
regardless right to get those challenges
or at least one right doing a couple
because of I of this week for flashpoint
so oh this isn't actually as big of one
as I thought it was and misspoke so yeah
that's a couple points and I was just a
couple coins let's look at the map god
gold is the soonest one and let me just
take you guys to IO get you guys it's
flashpoint done yet ones coming into the
giant skull alrighty
what is the special sprint for the Titan
called
are you talking about like the shoulder
charge like that little glow that he has
that's probably what you're talking
about
I know that one torch I got the
prosecutor at level 10 from client
Ingram job nice just infuse a Auto rifle
into it it's really good it's actually
mostly better than knee riyals almost
Orioles gifts almost slightly less range
and stability but we're sorry it's
slightly less range and handling I love
your gift yeah it's pretty good but once
you get this it's better than almost
better than your eels gift it's a yeah
it's got great handling which one you're
talking about uh I was comparing it to
the prosecutor right which I don't think
you have theirs I think I have it in my
ball urinals gift sure hello
schist Gaston Oh for Oh apparently
forgiven monster game and says you can
keep traveling fast traveling to winding
code to choose a faction coins
winding curve that's it's got to be etz
oh this one no I guess that must be one
that you can just do over and over
speaking to be urinals IO kind of looks
like I wonder if that's faster though is
that faster forgiving monster gaming
than like doing heroic public events
because I feel like public events our
pretty streamlined except for likes this
time we have this hold of point for a
while I feel like some of the other ones
are pretty probably gonna actually do
work I'm just saying so something I was
saying you could cheese coins in a
certain loss sector and they eat easy
but I'm wondering if it's just worth if
it's worth it compared to just doing the
heroic public event cuz the heroic
public event gives you eight coins doing
the law sector usually only Nets you to
earth to believe and then also from
doing heroic public events you also have
the chance of getting exotics whereas I
highly doubt you're getting dog whining
toad
maybe you can't maybe I'm wrong but I'm
sure he'll get an answer
thank you for the
you can check that out after in a second
and see if that is the viable strategy
fanatic what's the role for this one I
haven't done this we just stand on all
these plates right and eventually like
something oh right
I just haven't seriously just have not
been to IO every second ammendment class
Alecto being it's hard to say it depends
on what you want to do striker is
probably the most pinky of the three and
get Sun you got solar hammers are the
super you get striker as a super as saw
me running around and smashing stuff and
then you also get a Captain America seek
where essentially pretty cool pretty
cool as well as still the bubble from
the old game so its pretty solid
all-around warlock doesn't have self
resident war on it which is like a
pivotal skill and destined one which is
good I think but it has dawn blades so
you can use your user like flaming
swords to do damage where and then
there's Emperor Palpatine of course Tom
Lawlor yeah there's also my fav yeah
pretty good one you want to get that
with this other guy well I protected the
thing sure and then one of mine this and
then you get space magic with the Nova
bomb base magic it's just well it's just
one throw though right yeah but it's it
can eat the one of the bigger ones drops
axiom bolts to which is like pretty
crazy pretty good like yeah
and then finally you have hunter who is
probably argue we would have a probably
the best pvp class I would say cuz his
third class ability is kind of selfish
it's just Auto reloads like decree from
overwatch yeah oh I forgot about third
the possibility to title it Titans got
the shield he's also got rallying
barricade which is like a smaller field
that's auto reload your gun to be
crouched under it
whereas warlock has like a healing rift
which is pretty good at healing with or
or you can swap it speed damage which is
pretty good for the raid so I don't know
like it depends on what you want to do a
hundred to me by far oh geez is the
squishiest one by far is hunter so
want to play a spooky class
so yeah that's kind of a rundown we also
have a which class got best for you kind
of guide you want to check that out we
have that in
and I can give you a quick kind of like
rundown of just some of the abilities
that I mentioned in case they need to go
into further detail seaman action yeah
and then we also have like a really
specific class guide for each one so if
you're looking for a guide for that we
also have that on there to pick that up
hunter for the window oh yeah that and
that but hunters dodge that you're
talking about it is super enticing for
PvP for sure like yeah just get that
rhythm of the like behind cover up going
back and forth they're only knife is
also really good for what do we do
during faction rallies so once you allow
yourself the faction you're basically
farming for coins like you would for
like you know any other planets
planetary reputation and whatnot and
you're just trying to get the shaders
the armor pieces here and you know
hopefully you get what you want I am
dead orbit we got eight coins oh that
guy got an exotic gunny how you know he
says in the bottom left right there
above your oh you're you're right yeah
so we're also doing flashpoint io while
we're at it since we're like except
there's no public events all right so I
guess we could check out that whining
coat spot that uh forgiving monster
gaming was talking about go check that
out Rob since there's no public events
for us to do in IO Titan scum says John
Martinez what get out of here mister
dreadfuls got it right though dead orbit
baby oh yeah also warlock has that air
dodge to the old Twilight garrison
tactics so yeah Rob told me to go black
camo so this is my black camo dead orbit
shader got nasty and it got that nice
dead orbit supporter there and and then
I also got the the dead orbit Titan mark
which is pretty cool I kind of missed my
exotic dead orbit
mark from destiny one though that's
pretty cool yeah you could do as gif
Hughes or Jeff Hughes mentions you can
do crucible public events nightfall loss
sectors in the EDC those will all give
you coins there's also like as I
mentioned earlier new kind of public
events that give you coins to beast the
beast one five two five one loose orbit
all the way I agree goofs not mad at
that mark I'm not eating those weird the
knife only gave us five coins which you
would think that doing the night ball
would give you more than five coins
especially when a heroic public events
giving you eight so all right where's
this winding code the winding code ones
like right here right isn't it like in
the rocks it's in the rocks here so
let's go into here I think you probably
just keep doing it over I'm going the
wrong way all right you guys thing you
just keep doing it over and over maybe
they just quickly shoot all three of the
things and then like zombie punch says
hey I'm at school watching I'm kind of
glad you're watching but then at the
same time you're in school and I'm like
I can't promote that maybe it's free
period oh maybe it's this alright hold
on let me try this real quick oh no is
this this is count as leaving the area
Christ oh I wonder if it's like I jumped
into the rocks it's already there yes so
I'm wondering what I think what you need
to do hypothetically is you just keep
running to this first thingy and then
shooting it and then resetting it
potentially
watching from Ireland thanks for tuning
in
yeah so that guy's not there anymore but
I bet if I just came back here I'm gonna
do something for science rod I'm sorry
hey come in for the ride though up here
right neg past travel back 200 to
winding Cove even though I know I kind
of I want to see if this works I might
not have the right this might not be the
trick
oh you just left my fireteam no oh you
got a hot air oh all right help me back
right back good news is my stream or my
feet is the stream so got to watch all
that hot dying earlier it's pretty good
load of horse crap horse crap horseman
here oh crap okay
Oh hit the ceiling I'm just feeling
those since I shot this first one it
won't work but I'm not quite sure we go
out of the zone and go back in yeah yeah
but see like oh yeah okay so you can
totally do what I just did which is like
okay so you watch they can kill this
right
oh man you loaded again I don't know if
this is the way that these people are
doing it but I would assume that unless
there's another way yeah you need a fast
travel back yeah so you just keep going
out yeah in and out in and out
yeah I'm not really a big fan of the the
one coin here but I guess I guess in
theory you could do this if you really
wanted to would you do something like
this Rob where you just like kill one
thing get a coin probably not quick load
I I don't know but if someone's got this
like down to a science though and then
what next thing you know it's 2:00 a.m.
yeah every lunch yes that's just I'd
like to have a I should be learning my
detention make me go faster go this
thing oh no it's not there this time
maybe I did it too fast this time
anyways yeah but I just got here
I know hey but we're ultimately trying
to do your thing here for your
flashpoint man right trying to get your
flashpoint yeah let's get that
oh there's two objectives to blow up not
one oh yeah it's farther in but like I
thought that I thought the loop was that
you did the first one he just kept doing
it over and over I'm sure if I looked it
up or someone explained it a little bit
better we could show it off but I don't
know I don't like it you can do that if
you want to to get two coins I'd rather
just do heroic public events get eight
and like I got 117 coins in two hours I
bet you extra dice if we had if you had
two or a third and you just did heroic
public events for two hours I bet you
you would get more than 117 coins doing
the heroic public events versus doing
what you're doing is my guess because I
don't know like we could tie it we could
potentially time one of these right
robbed like because we don't have to
specifically do I owe one so we can jump
all over the map and look for the next
public event and if you're getting eight
each times each time and you have the
chance at her exotic in gram I'd rather
do this in a heartbeat and also this is
more entertaining to me yeah I don't
want to be going like into a cave fast
trap like killing do things like I did
that that other treasure chest cave
thing on necess but like I even I
couldn't stand that after
while this chest is here they're being
nice about it and like kind of just
totally like leaving it there whereas me
and your scumbag doing is open it oh
wait well we don't care dude that's what
it was like a high-value target see now
you have five people here I just feel
like I don't know they're gonna oh there
was a chest right there what you could
do the tighten just do the arms drop all
the way there's one in IO that has six
yeah I'm sure there's longer one but
like is doing that one longer one four
six gonna be as fast
I think so low yeah I would I would you
know my law secretary I guess but if you
have a group at all I think that doing
heroic public events is way bastard oh
god oh my god I got dumped on electro
bayonets asking what do you think the
future expansions will be well we know
ones already try it well we know both
ones trials related and one is Rasputin
related so definitely interested to see
where the trials one goes I think social
space would be mercury for that one I
think that's also confirmed so something
fresher this heroic event is one the
ships
got it Oh see here's that here's that
extra public event I was talking about
um so like you see those extra supply
drops if we hold those we get a coin for
each of those so we can go do that after
this I guess I don't know how long that
one live right let's say like we got it
this might be we just do both yeah I'll
go over there to go on Lisa's I can
still gauge it so it has these purple
guys guarding each one of these so it's
just like like sugreev or if I secure
this to 100% then that's one coin for
all of us we knock that ship out of sky
don't call PETA put your dog on a leash
oh I think I caught that big dude oh oh
you know what I might need to go shoot
that guy did you fall off the thing no
I'm I'm here
no no no but where's the boss guy I
haven't seen him yet well he's dead
right so cool we did that public event
now I got to do this other fella
oh cool cool stuff all right here we go
so we're gonna go sit on these things
until it's a hundred and you get four
more coins like I don't even know if
these are worth it cuz you gotta stand
on here for so long maybe it goes faster
with more people oh you guys got exotics
yeah I did
grats see this is why you got to do
heroic public of them I'm telling you in
the chat Rose watch I'm gonna get one
too I know you jinxed it that's fine
hello as one of us guess it proves the
point though you know like they're
trying to make a point man
I think these go faster with all of us
in the merrily yeah it's definitely
ticket oh it's gone it's going oh it's
gone it's gone
Oh going on here could be decent for
purple farming so yeah cool three of us
secured that we got a dead orbit token
we can stand over here when you're 20
now it says enemy supplies has been
claimed for the city so we've done a
good job for the city
nice man we're gonna stand on this this
plate now grab another one go some more
beads and then after this we're gonna
look for another public event
you just gotta rinse repeat you know
it's a great old time brand it's a great
time you got an exotic got it I'm having
a great Tuesday yeah I hope everyone
else's yeah
doctors not bad are we all standing a
little slower but now it's now it's
ramping up whoa I have the first time I
use it oh that yeah it's really good for
clearing out like a lot of guys but it's
really not that great one important
person but the cool thing is it does
reload when you just stand on it so we
got another one stand on what oh you
mean Stan if you pick up ammo well it's
it's not loaded you take a toll auto
reload we go yeah so it is really great
for like mass mouths yeah just like
clearing out a bunch of ads kill him my
sword
all right couple more seconds here
Coolio
what's up oh you know I didn't do it I
just want to say hi
oh hello oh hi how are you didn't I see
that guy
the master he's dead already
team it dancing his body he loves it how
I do this one oh good good work
yeah thanks back in the circle this guy
loves to dance Oh JM boy alright cool so
there's a little thing you could do
that's a new event and we got oh so a
lot we got eight out of that I lied so
you got you get um looks like you get
one for each one and then then you get
another four and you still get a chest
from it too I guess
look at that I'm gonna look for the
rupture so let's go to the rupture Rob
when you get away from these gladiators
that are trying to kill you roses are
red my item is blue your Ingram was
purple sucks to be you yeah oh he got me
has actually talked about his arm today
no because I hate that guy
I think most of the people in the office
actually don't like Asher I don't know
any I haven't heard anyone that's like
oh yeah I like that Asher guy the NPC on
this planet what do you mean nope just
like nobody likes him his personality
his personality yeah he's kind of
annoying like not he's oddly like I find
him more annoying than fail-safe who
actually I don't find that annoying
but some people can say that or what
she's got like the you know she's got
the schizo going yeah she's got a reason
to be annoying like she can't help that
all right he's just like overly nerdy
that's fair hmm no I'm all alone on this
planet doing my experiments it's a
lonely life being a scientist man
sometimes I can be yeah all right this
public event starts in two minutes and
for Scott
I'll mark it part time
I am are you yeah this guy's back
dancing Jam not in real life though the
one at the rupture right yeah yeah it's
two minutes
so it starts I'm just trying to do these
ones to get you guys the flash point cuz
like if you hold down your director you
hold down your director Rob yeah you
should be able to see how much your
progression you may have finished in
wine but you are 40% so it seems like
you need three more and technically you
can talk to the ball when you get back
right I want to do that we can end it
going to the tower and then I can blow
up some more dead orbit packages Oh get
close oh I almost have two more or I
almost have enough to to the specific
like pickups like phase glass you bring
that to Asher yeah it gives you a little
bit it's like it's like the same as like
getting tokens right actually I saying a
sure is a stubborn know it all yeah
sounds all right where do you find those
supply caches as shown in Delaware oh so
Chris Tobin you need to go to the e DZ
oh there's another one of those a little
sounded like well yep there's another
one of those little mini public do that
it's the same sound effects of the goal
posts oh okay yeah yeah it's like I just
saw the I heard the flare kind of thing
yeah yeah alright so let's go do that
real quick sure and then get our tokens
there and then we'll do that heroic
public or public event hopefully right
after it even though that one starts in
30 seconds so that is a little bit
worrisome
I don't know if we'll be able to do both
so I never played much of the first game
but it wasn't there like cool tricks and
moves you can do on your spare oh yeah
I'm still have that I think okay so
that's just obviously something you
would get out of like a bright Engram or
yep love it
I wonder if one of us can go do that one
oh this guy's here to doctor go to them
no no I meant like as I do like the
other rope oh yeah
like split up I can go back and engage
it yeah badass yeah because you guys
will still get the rewards I think for
this and this like you'll see because I
was wondering earlier while I was
getting like one random oh and I think
it's because people were just doing this
nearby and I think I miss your faction
you just get it so looks like so it's
cool
and I might need to go engage that one
and like this coming back if I get
credit
I'll just secure this one and then come
and help out yeah it's the same type of
life
what's your what's your favorite heroic
or yeah
we're okay back which is one because
like so easy quick easy but it's unique
to in a sense I playing I don't know
maybe because I'm so used to these ones
that like just like the way to have like
a high one or something yeah yeah that's
fair and it's kind of like the one on
its own I guess next one is whatever is
there really and there really aren't
that that's the only high one I believe
so yeah alright those supplies will have
to wait well I come to help out at the
kind of double public event yeah and I
think what's gonna happen to you at this
one rob is a taking guys in this bond
which is like how I was able to sell it
because the the boss guy was shooting
they're taking
you guys don't have one technically I
think when you beat the game you can get
one from the violet what happened nope
only shooting at the potatoman
ANCA just laugh come back oh it can't
sometimes it leaves really quick I feel
like the first time okay next time yeah
if you see it with Alma no I know I was
just like oh [ __ ] oh no it's coming back
takes a second
the ward is not good for that ship oh
gone oh we're difficult for to work with
would flip coil yeah I love the police
shift
oh no I want it sure
Oh might be good a lot of guys I was our
boy yet
here
see the other guys want
Oh
boys aren't always
Oh
Adam alright so this one's done you can
go do the other one well doing that
doubling that you started over come on
give me an exotic for the street
no they secure the supplies we're too
late
rip oh we got a kit now oh and we're
just too slow on that one I mean it's
hard to kind of divert your attention I
mean yeah it's always this and I mean
that's why we could have we needed to
kind of do the you go there and then you
go there and then do both right and this
in this case - they were like pretty far
away Jai Roth I pick dead orbit cuz dead
orbit for the life Oh Rob picked me
monarchy because he's a scumbag piece of
garbage actually I kind of picked it
based on convenience okay
that's Mary yeah you don't really have
Allegiance no I don't well I didn't play
the first game I don't I'm fresh did you
uh get right where'd you go - I went to
wherever that one on the top there lost
oasis lost oasis
boy I don't hide
what does extra dice mean pick up your
tacos and grab a gun was I mean no taco
so I am gonna eat a burrito you are he
said taco now I want to talk about yeah
yeah okay oh I don't know you messed
with the lengua huh
you messed with the languor at all
what's that language beef tongue oh dude
it's actually really good is it I didn't
tell you and you just ate it oh man
that sounds real if telling is legit
that sounds wrong in a way don't don't
don't lie to me what a minute
what would you compare to it depends on
how you how you have it sometimes it's
like very like just like circle shapes
and like thin circle like like this it's
very thin right but I've also had it
where it's kind of like chopped up and
that was like really good but was it
tastes like it's just tastes like beef
okay just have beef in it yeah it's a
cow's tongue JM cjm 76 who's down there
dancing he's sitting he said lenguas Bom
Hey oh it's Bom all right well some day
I think if I gave it to you and you you
ate it you and you didn't know you'd be
like oh this tastes pretty good
and then you've it and I'd be like oh
it's beef tongue or cow tongue yeah
Clare Cross gave you a shout out earlier
but I'll give you one more but that's
the last one you get yeah you've gotten
a lot Rob gave you one too I did where
can I find the best armour-wood
at at which class armor looks the best
we're doing the best art that's a that's
a meaty question there's a lot of armor
sets one for each planet or then there's
a couple of like vanguard and crucible
and then now the faction armor actually
and which one looks the best I think
which one looks the best is subject to
what you think
looks the best it's true we got to do
the blight thing let's let's try to do
it this signs just like beef tongue I
don't like this this is my least
favorite yeah but it's it's I like that
I like that it has a different mechanic
I think that it's kind of kind of cool
well they all that's different I can
kind of see how it's annoying but I just
yeah oh please don't kill everything
damn Oh or whoever you bat oh I super
hey did you kill the ball though no just
don't kill the ball don't go that up you
killed this ball you killed this big one
you use the buff you go in and out of
the small ball and then you shoot the
main ball in the middle Oh what yeah
that's why I said this one's cool so you
see that item that you have in the
bottom-left flight receding that allows
you to damage this bigger ball which is
what we want to do to trigger the heroic
public event yeah I learned something
today
five minutes
yeah you're gonna need to get the buff
again yeah
you stop it
you just died
here he comes the relied to make hey
that guy's different than the EDC I
didn't realize there are different ones
for each saw that ran backwards in that
guy and just stopped me they tend to do
that
turn around to a nice to put in the face
oh he punted me all the way to LA has
quite the distance
but what the hell
yeah finding
oh you got here
this guy's a freaking whoa bond right
there how about you oh he's almost dead
yeah just run rob yeah we did it eight
tokens easy money it's a boy boom
usually it works when I call it sea
giant scars right about to be up this is
like you're just going in a circle what
are the faction perks I don't think
there are any perks right now outside of
winning the the class the faction war
for the week which then allows you to
buy a weapon from your faction vendor
that is a 1,000 glimmer but it's like
supposedly wrote pretty good is the
rumor I don't know if it actually is
good because we haven't gotten to that
point yet but each each faction has its
own like weapons that it's selling like
new honor key was a sidearm yeah I think
okay is that don't worry to scout I
think and a new monarchy might be a
pulse I believe we need to take over the
plates
James going to one right now I can hold
down the fort if you guys want to hold
down some plates
all right this is my least favorite one
because it takes the longest yeah
yeah I don't know man I I still I'm
still on the the boat that this is
better than doing that other farming and
winding Cove but maybe I do think so any
around but you got an exotic which helps
prove the point a little bit and I can't
wait to go back to the tower yeah yeah I
started out I mean just just for me I
just know I like since last night after
we play it I like haven't done or little
boy at my stuff how yeah no worries it
does kind of get overwhelming when you
have to start doing some housecleaning
oh yeah I'm gonna plate now by the way
so I don't know if you guys done nope
yep
you sure does what I got a question if I
if my inventory is completely filled and
engrams dropping those automatically go
to the post the post okay
yeah always yes unless your post gets
but that would take Oh take a lot of
yeah and not cleared out your post and
be playing like quite a bit you know
yeah pretty difficult to do that's for
sure yeah prosecutors really good I
don't know if that's just in my head
because it I know that people are saying
is good but it feels really good oh [ __ ]
oh no this is my bad it's okay we can
afford it the last one
oh wow those things called the
disruptors the fanatics no sir just luck
there's that sorry I call fanatics cuz
that's what their they were okay it's
socially dangerous
I see I think they're still called
fanatics in some cases but they're also
in destiny one as fanatics
anything
didn't trigger the phone either while
yeah so watch out for Cyclops is there's
gonna be like two that are gonna like
and that hydro over there that's also a
problem I'll focus on the hi
there's one of the cyclopses almost got
my super that's a good name on now
Oh gone I see Cyclops under two and then
Keiko that guy was a [ __ ] tiger
he's dead
except I'm about to die okay you do you
Palpatine never goes out with the place
flank man down
cow out a high drag on
yeah it's not that's it well it's pretty
good I cleared a lot of the stuff that
Titan Smith
Hydra another one normal one being all
creepy creepy all right got another
eight tokens another chance for what
grenade launchers that says Jacob was
low speed it's the prospector exotic
milestone completed a really sick okay
cool that seems like a good time to go
back to the I think so
tower after we open his chest there's
the prospector you guys getting exotic
yep I think my exact look at that thing
check your wallet I'll excavation exotic
dams oh dear I think has cluster yeah it
does have cluster and then we go blue
rocket launcher with cluster I got to
keep that though Rob because I know what
I don't have one of them what were you
saying about cluster but they're pretty
it's pretty strong in PvE now it might
even look good for PvP but uh alright
let's go to the tower actually you know
what we're gonna do one more because
there's one right there there's one
right there how could they not yeah
there's always there's always one more
there's always gonna be set it already
there's always gonna be one way that's
cool that's chill
maybe I'll what is the best faction in
Wesley Hogan ass obviously dead orbit I
don't know why - hey man it's it's
faction day what do you what do you
think obviously I got a rep I wish I you
know what there was a long time ago I
was actually gonna buy dead orbit shirt
but it was always sold out but if I had
one I totally would have been rocking it
what Wi-Fi broadband you guys use we're
not on Wi-Fi broadband we're on like
corporate fiber Internet but that's a
good question
was it best action for a person who
likes Scout rifles oh that's actually
tough because the scout rifle at dead
orbit seems ok the the future war cult
one are we yeah a future work hall one
what's kind of interesting
it has rampage on it so I have what to
that with rampant rampage is one like
you kill something within that clip and
as you kill stuff you get more damage so
right now my origin story has rampage
right so am I like if there's something
to actually kill it would do more damage
than you can stack up to three times
right
I'm like the worst place
oh I forgot that I asked earlier but I
forgot it how can I change factions if I
can I believe well I'd have to take a
look at it in the in destiny one you
would just hold square and your faction
anything oh you would like like let you
get rid of it
oh but I don't know if they have that in
this one cuz I didn't see where the
faction token was so I'd have to take
away we can take a look at that in the
tower that is a good question that we
not that I would want to join Dan orbit
okay you know just the Thresher is here
by the way oh let me show on the rocket
no wait oh it's alright he'll come back
Dan try to use a lot of
do your boy
Jeremiah asks what do the factions give
in bonuses there's currently no bonuses
that I know
I know that you do get specifically from
doing their stuff and then the winner
for the week gets like a weapon drop
that's like a thousand glimmer the
faction that wins a week so technically
Oh what and how does a faction win we're
just like I think I should have read it
but my guess is like if you're the
faction does the best for the week oh my
god yeah
so much stuff on the screen I'm dead
yeah I like just like all this [ __ ] was
that because everyone is here right oh
yeah there are a lot of people here it's
like yeah because it's the oh and the
targets are doing this oh hey the other
public secure the thingies so let's go
do that it's just endless seconds and
endless cycles how they get you ah no
freaking exotics man making me look like
a doe a big boy toys oh I picked up toys
I said you can get exact doing this yeah
I did what is your drop in when your
Titan comes from that ship it's a hive
one it's a high base effect let me show
that to you guys
I think the Cabal ones really cool you
guys to see mad
how much that excuse you or bless you
rather yeah well it kind of sound like
this is David H said the framerate drops
on Xbox are terrible
but they're probably pretty similar here
oh hello that happens to that happens
you all the time I throw like jerk being
like what are the odds ma'am I was
recording too hot gameplay hot gameplay
- they're hot game what's funny I don't
I can't hear my audio but like I like
you can't know my um your voice ah no no
my game audio oh yeah why not because I
didn't switch to control it because it
was way too loud my controller and but
uh what's funny is like I like don't
notice when I'm like near you at all
oh really or just in general like
listening to your audio it's like got a
high-value target oh yeah but I see him
he's a real jerk sucking if they're
gonna be a dominating faction that
always wins every week I don't know it's
hard to say I was making the joke that
dead orbits always the win but you know
maybe not
I know that got chopped in eyedrops yeah
yeah I'm not too worried about that but
thank you
I know that so Mortal Kombat X had this
thing where it had factions - and I feel
like your turn oh that guy died though
that guy died at least oh yeah that guy
totally died
if you got smashed - that's hilarious
actually dammit all right we're gonna JM
here he like wasn't even a good in a
good spot
like it was like oh oh it was like on
the Supply Drop yeah almost the exact
same spot lesson learn whoa
I don't even know where it's safe right
now I'm so scared that I'm gonna drop
down again here and dumped on Oh see
there's there's a ship right there above
us are you you're gonna test the theory
yeah is that another one yeah yeah the
last name there's always four nobody
fireworks this one off oh really
yeah for another one that's hilarious
that's awesome actually
oh there's a big dude here oh he's gone
and teleported right all right oh I see
him please don't stop me
oh he did though
the Masters done did you kill him yeah
oh my god they're cleavers
so those are they call those those like
random public events that are new these
I don't know they just show up and oh
god aim from I don't know yeah
but when you finish all of them you get
four more it's like doing heroic public
event and just reclaiming supplies for
the city nope no exotic I got nothing no
a token oh yeah I swear it was over here
oh okay well we can explore real quick
if you want to or we could just get out
of the rabbit hole that we just went
down well let's just check real quick
okay okay I don't see anything is it on
the map or down here it would oh it
would pop up high like all right we're
the tower I think we had okay that's a
great great scream we're gonna wrap it
up Briah checking out our faction buddy
here I'm gonna turn in all this stuff
holy God oh no Rob I am one token sure
okay you know what oh yes I'm just gonna
go shoot that thing that's right at the
front for one coin so I could buy four
packages I think that's it's like it's
like uh you guys ever watched Chappelle
Joe Rogan what are we playing on ps4
yeah you can get chests I mean tokens
and kind of other words I mean you could
get tokens outside of chess - Wesley ho
GAE now you could do like patrols do
your challenges your your planet
challenges there's multiple ways to get
tokens but now there's now there's more
ways I guess than before
he's 294 drops oh I need to keep
cupbearer it's hilarious that that
rocket could be potentially just better
than a purple rocket to be honest yeah
alright just cuz of that just because
that pert it's really good for the last
boss in the raid calles because he just
stands still and he eats all and he's
like kind of like a bigger target so
just eat all of the don't what if it's
really short why don't you check on that
public event while I get us a token oh
my god sure gotta be efficient how long
it's just one menu we can go down this
rabbit hole forever huh
I should really alright well kind of
curious do you get do you get this token
no you don't
so what I have to be there yeah really
like just next to you I guess where is
this other one
okay oh is it this one Gabriel wants to
know the sensitivity you use I'm
actually kind of curious about that one
why you're in five so is that one more
up or just normal that's two more so I'm
just one more so in theory yo guys I'm
coming back to you with the winding code
30 seconds I'm good
alright I swear Rob I'll get there why
are you using the exotic Titan legs as
hi Kailen
well fun fact hmm I have the absolute
shittiest Titan luck ever
by the way I've actually made two Titans
in destiny - I deleted one a woman I
thought I could scam the system you
can't do that but I have not gotten
crest of alpha lupi chest I've not
gotten any Titan exotic at homes so now
I'm stuck with either using the lion
ramparts or the dune marchers or I guess
I guess technically this would be better
for me if the war rig just based on the
fact that I'm using double auto rifles
so I guess technically you could argue
that I should be using that but I really
wanted to be and I have to bang Paul
Jones but I haven't been running
Sentinel
minute so feel like i like i also i like
the you get an extra jump with iron
ramparts you get three there you get
three like a little ticks like one two
three no maybe I'm bad at jumping
Corvette will let I think says I
personally love the exotic Titan legs
drying my parts why though I thought I
just explained that maybe maybe it's
just cuz you have hello that's a garden
that guy died oh so did I yeah did you
get artillery yeah no you know having uh
now is that that was when those like
objects spawning I'll get killed by them
I got ya those weird like it says like
got killed by the artifacts or something
I didn't where you have a misadventure
now used in marchers so much better than
lying rampart you think so definitely
strange that's fair they look really
cool though I will say I aesthetically
like how do you are injured look so I
could always do that
thanks for the suggestion guys I
appreciate yo where that ship at it's
really high up
get down where is it it's a coming
around it's gonna come around zip each
and then it should show up like almost
like a final challenge
Oh J and Golden Gun six shots dawn
it is done right Boston show how fast
this is got him down
whoa big man
funky came along
see look at that rock that was like so
worth it
and I'm gonna get an exotic out of this
yeah I got a feeling you guys yeah yeah
this is it wake up bright and grim nicey
good thing we get it
boob didn't get it yeah oh you know what
though I'm full it would probably still
tell me if all right I got that look at
the map Rob I'm not allowed to look at
the bed at Duffy or Edie Duffy I am dead
orbit he is new monarchy he's not even
rockin his emblem because why would he
and then our rune wings in the game
Corbett I don't I didn't know they were
actually in there but yeah I've been
having a crappy look and then JM is
future war cult but yeah just so you
guys know we're gonna wrap it up here in
a second so get in your last minute
questions comments all that stuff but
we're gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna go buy
four packages how many can you buy we
can't show yours that was a problem
actually you know we should do hmm
oh boy your knee why can't a warlock I
already got all the gear oh wait you got
an exotic what well that was that
exciting that's hot that's hot rod
that's real hot get out of here hey
maybe one of my purples will turn exotic
have you had that happen it happens very
rarely yeah it can happen though when
you when you turn it in
bump Y void for the nightfall I say void
because a lot of the shielded guys I
felt like in the nightfall when we were
doing it we're like all void or like I
felt like there like void or maybe it
was it was like twenty eighty percent
eighty void yeah yeah I just felt like I
felt like some day it was mostly void
but I don't know if it's because I just
didn't have void and I was like oh my
god is void and I can't do anything to
him but uh Jam got blue screen that's
been happening more recently I don't
know why but yeah you still haven't
gotten your subclass yet why is that
asked Jeff used that's a good question
like I said I did two titans I've just
been really lazy doing the solar
subclass because I haven't really needed
it not even the raid so that's my reason
I wish I should do that
here we go here we go
oh the funds go here we go give me an
exotic exotic exotic recive alpha lupi
said I never had one now I have one it
went to my postmaster could that on his
face I called it robbed all right what a
good day what a great day I want to ask
for another one but it's highly unlikely
so much all right that was pretty cool
that was pretty cool rub pretty cool
should we call it yeah oh I did get an
exulting gram
suck it oh I'm sorry what suck it don't
write call you out that's right I got an
exotic Ingram too for those that didn't
telling us the cheese you know cheese
when you know cheesy succeed oh I got
the tractor cannon oh I don't I don't
know maybe there's like a way to use it
that like I don't know about but like
dude that was that was sick dude Ingram
- oh man yeah
yeah tell them to eat it GUP tell me I
didn't say she's come to eat it I don't
want to eat it
i watch watch all right here we go here
we go one of these this purple is gonna
turn exactiy what do you think is gonna
be you think I'm gonna get a dupe I'm
probably gonna do yeah you're gonna get
do please be vigilant women yeah I've
gotten three of these pieces of garbage
the fighting lion ruff yeah it's pretty
rough well that was uh it went from real
it's just what I get for talking to rob
this Sukkot I deserve that
I very know it was all fun I very much
deserved that
that's what I get for the three or four
not even a 3:05 what that do what that a
half all right real quick once you
switch your screen back to the things so
you can close out in a second while I
read my mom go buy some more dead orbit
packages
what is your favorite Titan subclass oh
man that's tough I was really digging
Sentinel because it was like super fun
to play like a newer subclass but man
striker with just having the full meter
like multiple smash has to be the best
way
clean your post master before you do
stuff Eric dude there's so much space in
the post bah it's gonna be fun
yeah DVI one haunted Earth this is the
Scout that you would get if you finished
faster reload when crouched all right
here we go
armored that's not armor that's another
three of graves and your faction guy
looks super depressed yeah dude he's
he's giving me depressing loot - yeah
okay I already got that shotgun - all
right well we got the gloves at least
they all went to the poster thing so I
got two pieces of dead orbit right now
that's all we got unfortunately yeah but
yeah cool you want to go send us out of
here Rob
sure well I clear out more this junk and
I'm a junk Rob alright well that was fun
thank you guys for joining us yes that's
our weekly destiny to stream we had a we
had a good time today oh yeah it was a
great time great time great stuff we
learned some things about the the new
public event yeah I mean there's a
there's like a new variation it wasn't
in the game before so yeah it just seems
like it's more streamlined there's just
more stuff to do and obviously I hope
you guys have fun doing that today on
reset day and until the next Tuesday you
know for more yeah
destiny stuff also tomorrow lobby of
course my Lobby Thursday early in the
morning we're gonna we did it last time
for the reveal of that first trailer
we're gonna try to don't know what's
gonna happen other
then Rockstar has like said they're
gonna make an announcement at 8 a.m.
right yeah so we'll have to see
Oh goob just said I just noticed craft
Punk did you know that I cannot die
craft Punk yeah that's about it and then
Friday I think we're gonna do
it's a Call of Duty World War 2 PC open
beta so we'll take a look at let you
play oh god I was hoping you would not
say that maybe some better at that game
I'm intimidated by the cod kids and
their mouse and keyboard skills
I'll get rekt but it'll be fun
regardless it will be fine okay
thank you guys so much for joining us Oh
show your ship droppin things sure all
on sigh rod no problem it's this thing
hi everywhere you go alright
dead orbit for live what a cool looking
ship that over it for life seriously
you're not that orbit you're dead to me
Oh harsh but I appreciate your
dedication alright guys have a great
Tuesday yeah dead over for life remember
that
you